[Music]
in tonight's buddy check one in eight
women under the age of 40 will be
diagnosed with breast cancer and it can
be a devastating and often surprising
diagnosis especially since screenings
aren't typically recommended until 40.
self-exams are often the way that that
cancer is discovered
i don't want to be sick felicia labounty
tearfully sharing her cancer struggle at
29 a lump was initially discovered and
dismissed as a cyst eight months later
it was stage four breast cancer my
breast cancer was a firm knot that i
know wasn't there before just last month
we introduced you to alexandra lightning
who was diagnosed at 33.
both women are undergoing life-saving
treatment breast cancer in women under
the age of 40 is really quite rare rare
but still rattling susan brown is senior
director of health information and
publications at susan g komen she knows
the odds of breast cancer under age 40
are very low 0.04 percent it's about 11
000 women under the age of 40 are
expected to be diagnosed with breast
cancer in the united states this year
the guideline for the first mammogram is
at age 40 unless there's a family
history or other risk factors but in the
case of la bounty or lightning they had
neither younger women typically have
dense breasts on mammography which makes
breast cancer hard to detect and so the
test just isn't as effective in younger
women as it is in older women both
discovered theirs through breast
self-exams so the message here be your
own health advocate insisting on
screenings and more tests even if
they're not required for labounty
sharing her struggle is part of her
healing trying to hold it together but
i'm not doing a very good job
by the way the average woman's risk of
developing breast cancer during her
lifetime is about 12 percent but you can
catch it early by getting a mammogram
and it's the eighth of the month so
that's the day we encourage you to call
your buddy and remind her to do her
breast self exam brian